across most major religions in the
country children have been abused
it is the latest damning report from the
independent child abuse inquiry it
looked at 38 groups from christian sex
to orthodox judaism and islam and found
shocking failings
lacie jones was abused from the age of
10 by an elder in the jehovah's witness
community
it just rips me apart
sorry because
it was like why aren't you helping me
and i just sort of screamed
loudly and led forward and just screamed
and cried and they didn't say anything
they didn't look at me
and that still devastates me because
you're brought up to trust them that
they'll look after you they'll protect
you now seeing the ixa
um
findings is once again another blow
absolutely devastating because i don't
think things will change
the report said as many as a quarter of
a million children received some form of
supplementary schooling from a faith
organization but of 446 places of
worship only 37 percent had up-to-date
criminal checks on staff that worked
with children they found that 10 of sex
abuse suspects investigated between 2015
and 2020 were linked to a religious
organization in the modern age it is
absolutely inexcusable that we have
organizations like this
who care for many hundreds of thousands
of children up and down the country not
having basic protection policies in
place i think that is astonishing but
can change really be forced in these
groups
we have no power to force organizations
to change
that the role of any inquiry is to to
look at the evidence
but ultimately it is for the government
and others to put in place the measures
that will make those things happen
and confidence that recommendations will
turn to action is crucial the report
says quite rightly that every religious
organization every religious group
should have a safeguarding policy that's
clearly something that needs to happen
it's a scandal that that hasn't been the
situation
to date so that's a change which needs
to happen but as i say we need much
bigger change in order to protect
children in these settings in the future
sky news has this week been exposing
allegations in the jehovah's witness
community spoken to those who felt they
had nowhere to turn but today's report
found failings in every religious
organization it looked at blatant
hypocrisy it said in the places where
children were meant to learn about right
and wrong ali fortescue sky news